[Musique]
concevoir les enfants bonsoir notre
nounours et très élégant aujourd'hui et
il a même pris son parapluie
moyo patron ce n'est pas par ap
c'est mon parachute d'hommes volants
plus besoin d'échelle avec mon parachute
je suis en un clin d'oeil chez mes
petits amis il fait attention nounours
qui va te faire très mal
vous allez voir ce que vous allez voir
patron attention j'ouvre mon parachute
et à trois choses 1 2 et 3
voilà vous couvre le veux tu venais me
dire voilà ce qu'est ce qui t'arrive
je tombais ouvre le jeu voulu faire le
malin et je suis tombé j'ai voulu oui à
lanvollon euros mais pas tous mondon sur
ie on va te soigner pour votre dernier
assure toi la porte les médicaments
nicollin ou ne bouge sur tout à nouveau
voilà madame l'infirmière tout d'abord
un peu de vinaigre
là encore nous avons déjà eu une petite
cuillère de miel là comme ça comment tu
te sens maintenant annonces autour de
grosses douleurs et ça ira beaucoup
mieux mon cosmo maintenant pour te
guérit tout à fait vous va t'acheter
notre chanson tu veux nous conformons
écoute c'est la fin de la journée
c'est le moment de ce congé nous faisons
comme nos amis il s'en nourrit
nous y allons offrir sans nuage
j'en suis certain le marchand de sable
vient il nous dira mais vos yeux et
dormait tous les deux nous sommes bien
dans notre lit nonos fouette avoir nui
sa grosse mois en fait plaisir quand je
vais m'endormir
quand je vais m'endormir safrane où les
plaisirs les petits le sucreries grosse
offre
[Musique]
connu une hausse à demain tenus nicolas
cornu comprenez temps bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous voyez c'est très dangereux de jouer
à l'homme volant avec un parapluie
il ne faut jamais faire comme nounours
qu'il aurait pu se faire encore beaucoup
plus mal hein
te voilà gros farceur comment un sentier
très bien patron nicolas et pimprenelle
m'ont bien soigné mais je ne
recommencerai plus aurora non tu as bien
raison nounours allons en route
bonne nuit les enfants fait bourrel
fêtes de bourg heures me
[Musique]